star citizen director chris roberts has
responded to criticisms about the
lengthy development of the game which
kicked off with a fundraising campaign
in 2012 that has since raised 132
million bucks and count the game has
still not been fully released the
initial target release dates have come
and gone due to the game growing in size
and scope in a candid blog post robert
said that cloud Imperium games have
decided to now share target dates that
are subject to change and will be
transparent about their development
schedule and progress he explains that
target dates are not release dates and
everything you see will shift at some
point sometime sightly and sometimes
wildly the danger in doing that has been
that casual observers will not
understand this that there'll be an
outcry that delays every time we update
the page while that is a risk above all
we trust the community that has given us
so much support beginning with star
citizen alpha 2.6 cloud Imperium will be
sharing their internal development
schedule on a weekly basis as a
permanent fixture on the Roberts space
industries websites Roberts added the
simple fact is that game development
especially game development on the scale
of star citizen is complicated if you
talk to any developer that works on
large titles they will tell you that
schedules especially earlier in the
development cycle move all the time most
people never see this because the
publisher won't announce a project
publicly until it's very far along for
the full blog post and updates on the
progress of star citizen check out our
story on GameSpot